de l'avis site où caen est astucieux
belle baie
la plus jolie le plus sérieux
à jouer et la vie de vouloir devenir
amis
et là nerveux aujourd'hui tout cas moi
je les [ __ ] est belle ah bon qu'est ce
qui s'est passé j'ai été attaqué par un
hiver au il a voulu me clouer le bec
non mais vraiment c'est pas croyable à
la vie mais tu sais on lui on est plus
tranquille matin tous mes fils oh la la
le petit jeu de la géographie c'est ce à
quoi tu te laisses graphique dit bonjour
à tous nos amis en même temps bonjour
mais salut à salut bonjour mais chirac
gros je vois que tu es discipliné
maintenant alors une carte de géographie
elle est derrière toi oui un drapeau
drapeaux et comment au jour bonjour dans
la langue du pays
voilà commençons par la carte de
géographie du pays en kiosque c'est pas
commode comme hot a et on n'a pas
beaucoup
lyon c'est un pays bien allongé sa le
pays qui est tout hologram
ici nous avons la capitale voilà voilà
bon yann zimmer oui il ya de la mer
beaucoup de maires beaucoup de beaucoup
de mai beaucoup disent oui c'est ce
faisable
j'en garde quand même le drapeau mais ça
me paraît assez faisable
ah oui fond rouge
et oui on trouve son rouge croix blanche
et croix bleue
voyez tu vois oui je vois très bien joué
alors le comment dire bonjour dans la
langue du pays
après ça va pas être commode ça moi je
crois que ça a dit jack de godard drogue
tag prix kodak
bonjour rouge vous avez trouvé vous
voyez de quel pays il s'agit le drapeau
god d'agde
et puis cette carte de géographie et a
tout simplement de la norvège
c'est la norvège qui est un pays très
maritime voyez toutes les cotes très
très longue et la capitale au fond d'un
fjord un fjord c'est un bras de mer qui
rentre dans la terre c'est au chl aux
célébrités frais et par d'éventuelles
danemark un pauvre hère commencent ils
demeurèrent comment seul dans sa cellule
à marcel marx a sûrement pas un sas et
la norvège je suis désolé danemark c'est
ici
alors quand on ne sais pas monsieur
gentiment mais leur arrive quand on ne
sais pas monsieur tout comme quand on se
tait voilà c'est tout l'uhsa mois noir
sur blanc ils ont menacé la norvège
incapable je m'en vais parce que tiens
tu es mauvais en géographie comme c'est
pas pensa alors j'ai vécu et il ne
m'aura pas comme ça que quand tu sais ce
qu'on va plus de 29 ans tient au courant
et oui et là je du point comme elle
n'est pas dit alors on était fébriles on
l'appelle au mco alors qu'on est à l'air
tout mou fabrice walla walla walla
gerry's tu en viens de gervais bardot
qui en viennent aux gens viennent
norvège que 2 a pris pour le danemark
n'est ce pas comme ça je me suis bien
amusé sur tout le monde s'amuse de
sheikh ahmed qu'on me dit on y va on y
va
le point commun le jeu de points communs
je te préviens alors ça aussi c'est très
difficile oui on va je mange en
ressentira pas si je m'en sortirai je
fais partie des dessins alors pas des
dessins artistiques 1 qui représente des
bouquets de fleurs des paysages des
peintres ou non moi je suis quelque
chose de très précis qui a par exemple
une maison vue d'en bas dos et dans mon
cas de profil
ben tu vois avec toutes les mesures la
hauteur des étages des escaliers des
fêtes enfin c'est ce qu'on appelle du
dessin industriel
bon alors moi ce que je représente vous
pourriez l'admirer si je retirais mon
chapeau mais non je ne le ferai pas car
je viens justement d'aller chez le
coiffeur
il m'a fait quelque chose d'assez réussi
mais que le moindre courant d'air
pourrait détruire au fabrice cela te
surprendre est dévoyée ma coiffure
j'ai des cheveux beaucoup moins long
qu'avant je trouve que ça me va très
bien
sam de nageurs plus moderne tout à fait
dans le bon ces sites est extra enfin
remarque toi aussi
quand tu vas chez le coiffeur tia droit
c'était
cette chose que j'aie représente
qu'est-ce que ça peut bien être que ça
inc un sens bah je vois pas pour
l'instant je suis bien embarrassé via
mon secours pour ce monsieur s'il te
plaît parce que ça va pas du mois moi je
attends je m'excuse et toi je vais vous
étonner
bon mais déjà mais déjà ma voix va vous
étonner mais parce que j'ai attrapé un
coup de froid
alors j'ai des difficultés oui oui je
disais donc je vais vous étonner
parce que vous pensez sans doute que je
suis pas très sportif
et pourtant ce que je représente tous
les amateurs de sport et
particulièrement les amateurs de
football le connaissent bien
quant aux joueurs noirs football
français la patinoire voudriez vous mon
cher rapide au g1 et rapide hausse avec
moi et j'ai dit oui
vous deviez vous m'aider et mon chien
rapide aux acteurs évoluent ils vont
plus être une fille un grand pays et
bien ses joueurs se battent tout au long
de l'année pour obtenir et ça m'amuse
bien moi de regarder je te garantis
qu'ils se donnent à fond et plus la
saison avance - lille reste deux
prétendants à l'or comme il ne reste
plus que deux et qu'ils se battent pour
savoir lequel sera l'heureux vainqueur
quelle battle pour lesquels joie pour
celui qui ment porte dans ses bras et
oui oui et bains les bains les bains et
ben je suis dans une drôle de panade
parce que je ne vois pas très bien tu
m'as parlé dessin industriel tout cancon
et puis toi tu m'as parlé de chevelus et
oui c'est ça
et toi tu m'as pas être joueur de
football je suis peut-être ensuite je
sais pas alors là je là franchement je
suis bien là bas c'est peut-être une
pointe pour dessiner
j'ai vu mon nom et je n'ai jamais fait
refaire les prisonniers d'êta oui on a
même failli me kidnapper on a même
kidnappé un jour oui dans le vestiaire
sais pas si vous voyez pas oui tu veux
parler de d'une coupe
merci d une coupe bien entendu ça ira
mais je n'avais pas trouvé le bon jour
je ne sais pas si vous étiez embarrassé
comme moi une coupe bien sur wii ne
coupent de dessin oui une coupe quand on
va chez le coiffeur wii et enfin une
coupe de football tous à bâle à zaïm à
voir merci rapido je perds mes amis que
moi aussi je vais coller fabrice dans
mon petit jeu musical oui c'est j'ai vu
plupart à quelque chose d'assez
croustillant à côte alors bon alors
voilà en tout cas encore alors voir au
revoir ma petite belbel labrousse
mousseux dit dans bams ah oui ça va être
à nous battre et j'aimerais si tu
pouvais me donner un petit verre d'eau
ça m'arrangerait bien tout à l'heure
tout à l'heure je pense que là je n'ai
pas sous la main alors notre jeu notre
jeu avec le le tableau et les lettres
oui oui oui ah bon alors cette semaine
louis un mot en huile être tu m'entends
bien en vilaine tu m'entends bien belge
temps je t'entends bonbons alors à mios
en huile est en vie depuis
oui ça commence par là et bien là la
première c'est un p 1 p combien ville
est alors qu'amd être deux trois quatre
cinq six les enfin la huitième lettre d
un d or en bo3
hier roi tu es d'accord rapide hausse
oui oui bon et toi tout quand on sait
pas très bien aussi oui oui tu sais pas
du tout de quoi il s'agit d'accords
alors qu'est-ce que ça peut bien n'être
que ça c'est assez alors c'est un animal
comme d'habitude nous nous cette fois
c'est une fleur
non c'est pas une fleur non plus à dos
c'est un arbre impôts un arbre alors je
sais pas moi qu'est ce que c'est un tas
fruit est presque à fruits et légumes à
légumes à légumes allaient veux tu que
je te donne une aide supplémentaire s'il
te plaît oui la troisième la troisième
un troisième essai teintées a été hâtée
voilà et une liste à légumes algues
oui c'est pas un petit pois c'est bon
d'ailleurs très bons légumes fruits
n'ont fait de la soupe de la bonne sous
la souris didon bien pour ma gorge
d'ailleurs dit dont nous dit dans wii
illustrant le potiron le potiron il
aspire et bâtir il adoubé opinion c'est
ce que veut que la brimer mais petit
rond mon pauvre pouces moussu s'écrit p
o
après dit oui après après round1 marron
c'est comme ça que tu écris potiron un
petit rond devant tous les enfants te
crie potiron comme ça oui je juge suit
est ce que seront les axes et les ronds
potiron v900 voyons il n'y a pas de d
absolument pas petit nom s'écrit
d'impôts et aux trn tout simplement
rollandin coûte alors ça s'est passé
quand je te parle d'un chouette je
tâcherai de me le rappeler
oui ma chérie en tout cas ce que je
n'oublierai jamais alors ça c'est ce que
j'ai appris en parlant à des gens qui
connaissent bien bien les petits ronds
et savait que c'était très gros des
potirons un rapide hausse mais jamais je
n'aurais pensé que je vais peser 100 kg
sur m6 ce soir à l'hôtel où tu savais
toi tu savais où sans kiwi jauniaux sens
ultime dans la région où l'état pas de
faire du bien eh ben dis donc aux
messieurs je savais pas ça peut sentir
pour un petit rond sans dégâts
extraordinaires
nous allons rejoindre dell belle je
pense oui car elle l'a son petit jeu
musical qui est prêt attention risque
la twa fabrice gars jouer avec moi c'est
pas si la musique du beta bonjour ma
petite affaire
mon petit pas mais nous allons jouer
notre jeu habituel mais bien c est à
dire que tu vas complété par des notes
de musique
certains mots de la petite histoire que
je vais te raconter oui et que je
remplacerais mois par les bruits divers
foyers soit par des sans papiers sur les
micros parce que oui
ah bon et la fin tu verras que toutes
ces notes formeront le début d'une
petite chanson que tous nos petits
camarades connaissent surtout ne
t'inquiètes pas j'ai tout près par abe
bon alors si tu commences c'est tout
préparé wall et bien tu l'as mis où il
se réclame yamba n'ont jamais ans et
qu'il faut que tu le met un baba je vais
te le mettre en bon alors voilà
la voilà tu sais je vais te raconter
l'histoire d'une petite fille à qui on a
causé beaucoup de soucis
oui beaucoup de soucis cette petite
fille je devrais dire cette jeune fille
car elle avait 18 ans voulait se marier
mais pas avec n'importe qui elle ne
voulait pas de philippe lui de france
soigne de dico des données quoi ni déni
quand la lettonie la absolument ses
parents qui proposait même détresse des
ducs
mais quand on leur parle et il ne
répondait même pas elle restait lancieux
ces lieux la voile et où elle préféré un
mariage tout simple sain cérémonie elle
ne tenait pas être comblé de ko de
cadeaux de cadeaux des cadeaux
seulement elle voulait épouser le garçon
qu'elle aimait et qu'il aimait lui en
plomb les eaux où ça il le met lui au au
blue book
les mets au coin où ce aussi aussi ah
oui aussi oui malheureusement on réussit
garçon était tailleur oui oui oui il
n'était pas été pas il n'était pas là il
n'était pas là haut le malheureux il
était en prison
enfermée dans un cachot et condamné à la
poupe itude à à la solitude à la sema la
tuque honnête ou regarde les notes lille
et moi récit ainsi docile à sol ce qui
se chante bien
image
là
la nouvelle est l'amour
voilà mais c'était pas marrer c'est le
moi tu vas pas tellement d accompagner
aba show ne peut pas en même temps jouer
et chanter tu sais c'est trop c'est une
fête nous répéter ensemble
en attendant on va chanter notre petite
chance aux habituels j'en ris les quatre
amis d'accord qui la connaissaient pas
ce qu'ils pensent elle est tout le temps
les tapis c'est déjà pas permis
d'établir que la vie me désiste léger
choc et des chances mais comme génipa
demi noir mais gros rabais
attention les quatre amis sont partagés
sans répit leygnac ça me sens heureux
d'arisem amis
oui
pour jouer aujourd'hui vouloir devenir
amis
m
la merde
e
hélas